مرحبا من ملاحظه توجه النجمات المهن
مغايره عن الشكل التقليدي السائد للمراه
في السينما والدراما في عده مسلسلات في
هذا العام ابرزها ظهور روبي او عمده في
مسلسل حضره العمده بعد ما ظلت التلفزيون
او مخلص لنموذج المراه التقليدي طوال
عشرات سنوات مضت وهو امر يبدو ان
المشاهدين احبوا حيث تاتي اصداء العمل
جيده بشكل ملفت انا مسلسل حضره العمده
اللي عجبني فيه ان هو مهمه
بناقش تمكين المراه اولا
قضيه الختان
جواز القاصرات الاجره غير شرعيه فهو بناقش
قضيه مجتمعيه مهمه جدا في اي مسلسل في اي
عمل اكيد يعني لازم توصل له حاجه في الاخر
توعيه يعني فالمسلسل
عجبني للنقط بصراحه طبعا من خلال الشخصيه
انا بحاول اساعد العمده مع اني برضو عندي
حته زي اي راجل عنده فكره تشكك في الاول
في المراه انها هتقدر
يعني تحتل هذه المكان القياديه وانها تمشي
خصوصا في مجتمع الشنب هو المجتمع الذكوري
الريفي البسيط
ها كما انه يجمع اجيال مختلفه حيث يشهد
حضره العمده منافسه في التمثيل من
الفنانين المشاركين فيه في قريه التل
شبوره اللي ترمس في العمل الى مصر معبرا
عن بعض المشكلات الاجتماعيه اللي اثارت
الجدل كزوجه مثلا لما اري الدور طبعا
عجبني يعني وحسيت فيه بحاجه جديده اول مره
اعملها هو شخصيه مسعود المجبراتي اللي
بيبيع
حاجات كثيره قوي عشان يسفر ابنه طبعا شفته
في الحلقات اللي تعرضت ان ابنه توفى في
البحر ليه الهجره الغير شرعيه فطبعا هي
ماساه طبعا يعني
وعزها لجميع الشباب اللي موجودين دلوقتي
ان هم يشوفوا بيبيعوا كل حاجه هنا عشان
تشتروا الموت
المسلسل فعلا في فكره ذكيه جدا فكره ان هو
بيلخص يكاد يكون مصري كلها في القريه اللي
بتدور فيها الاحداث اللي هي تل شبوره يعني
من خلال كده بنقدر نشوف بقى كل الطوائف
المجتمع وبنشوف كل الناس وبنشوف
وبنشوف رد الفعل على الاحداث حصلت في
المجتمع المصري فتره فاتت دي كلها
[موسيقى]
لستوني كتير وفجاه عزتني انت واخواتك يومي
وكمان تقول لي عايزينك عمده بلدنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات